- [Announcer] This program is presented
by University of California Television.
Like what you learned?
Visit our website, or follow
us on Facebook and Twitter
to keep up with the latest UC-TV programs.
(bright music)
- Welcome to A Conversation with History.
I'm Harry Kreisler, at the Institute
of International Studies.
Our guest today is Nell Irvin Painter,
a leading historian of the United States.
She is the Edwards Professor
of American History
Emerita at Princeton University.
She is the author of many books,
including Creating Black Americans,
Standing at Armageddon,
a Grassroots History
of the Progressive Era, and most recently,
The History of White People.
Professor Painter, welcome to Berkeley.
Welcome back to Berkeley.
Where you born and raised?
- That's two different answers.
- [Harry] Yes.
- I was born in Houston
Hospital for Negroes.
And I was raised in Oakland, California.
I consider Oakland my hometown.
And looking back, how do
you think your parents
shaped your thinking about the world.
My parents shaped my thinking
about the world fundamentally.
First of all they were,
to the extent that my,
you know, my mother is no longer living,
my father is still alive, they
were very liberal, very left.
So I grew up in a pan-African
left wing household
that didn't accept sort of
conventional standards for women.
And I was always encouraged
to do what I wanted.
I always felt I was okay.
And that I could.
- And your father was here at Berkeley?
- [Nell] Many years, many years.
- And your mother was in
the Oakland public schools.
- Yes, my father was chief
technician of chemistry
in Lewis Hall, room 19
Lewis Hall for many years.
And I grew up on the campus actually.
My mother, for many years,
did not have a career,
but when she started
her career in the 60s,
she actually started in the Ed School here
at the University of California Berkeley,
and then moved to the
Oakland public schools.
Both my parents retired in 1982.
And my mother decided she
wanted to do something new.
She started writing books.
- So, so education and the notion of,
having your eye on achievement
were very important.
- Yes, but I never felt that I had
to do this, or I had to do that.
My parents were just very supportive
of whatever it was that I was doing.
Which, the older I get, the
more grateful I am for that.
- And what was conversation
like around the dinner table?
- Well, we did have conversation
around the dinner table.
Most of it I don't remember,
but one moment stands out
very clearly, and this
would have been about 1952.
And I was reading, we all
read the Oakland Tribune.
Which in those days was
a very Republican paper.
And it was backing Dwight Eisenhower.
Time for a change, it said.
And so I said at the dinner table,
well, it's time for a change.
(both laugh)
- That's very good.
So here, I mean, the Bay
Area obviously became
a center for Afro-American,
Black activism.
How did that impact you?
- We were not specifically involved.
My father was not a Pullman
porter or anything like that.
But the whole feeling of the
Bay Area was very progressive.
And we were very progressive.
So it was more a kind of
atmosphere that I grew up in.
And I am so grateful that my parents,
my parents married very young.
They married at 19 years old.
And they agreed that they
must get out of Texas.
And so as soon as they could, they did.
And only once did I go back.
I was not one of those kids who
was sent back in the summer.
And every now and then I say to my father,
I'm so glad you left Texas.
And he says, me too. (laughs)
- I laugh because I'm from Texas.
In fact, you're from Houston
and I'm from Galveston.
A little more about the
influence of your mother.
You're a great writer.
And was she an influence there?
Tell us a little about that.
- My mother taught me to read and write.
I knew how to read and write
before I went to school.
I knew how to read the
Wizard of Oz, to be exact.
And I spent many years in
my youth away from home,
so my mother was my great correspondent.
And all those letters, at least for me,
are in my archive at the
Duke University Library.
So my mother was crucial in
teaching me to enjoy writing.
I love to write.
And I'm still writing actually.
- And later in her life,
she became a writer.
- She did.
- And published a book.
- She published two books.
- Two books.
And so you were able to
return the favor to her,
now being a distinguished historian.
- Well, more than that.
Yeah, more than that.
She inspired me to change.
You can change after 65.
I was 68, going on 69 when I got my MFA
from the Rhode Island School of Design.
And if I hadn't had my mother's example
of starting anew at 65, I'm
not sure I could have done it.
- Now when you were coming,
when you were maturing,
in public school, were
you struck by the dearth
of historical materials
on African-Americans?
- Absolutely.
- What was the response,
and how did your parents
help you with that?
- Well, I was always a troublemaker.
And I think I'm still
considered a troublemaker.
But I remember sitting in homeroom,
and would this have been in
Claremont Junior High School,
and seeing, it was the Henry Ford mural.
You know, where all
the European immigrants
go in their national
costume, and then they get
in the boiling pot, they become Americans,
and they come out wearing
their suits and ties.
And every week, I sat under that.
And finally I said, how come there are
no black people in there?
And (makes shushing sound),
that is not a good question.
So, you know, all the time, all the time,
I would bump up against
this sort of thing.
I was in gifted classes
in junior high school
and high school, I went to Oakland Tech.
And I was very good in history.
Actually, I was good in everything.
But I was really good in history.
And we got tested toward the end.
What's your aptitude and
what's your interest.
And I was like astronomical
on both in history.
And I said, well that
proves that these tests
don't know anything because
I hated history's guts.
Because I knew it was a pack of lies.
And I said to my teacher,
where is segregation here?
What's going on here?
I grew up with From Slavery to Freedom.
So I knew that there was stuff there
that I was not being taught, so.
I did not graduate from
Berkeley in history.
I did not, I tested out
of US history on purpose.
I didn't want to take it.
- And your parents helped,
pointed you toward the black heroines
and women who, who were not in the books.
- Not particularly.
- No.
- They encouraged me to read.
They encouraged me to read everything.
So, you know, we're talking
way before feminism here.
So they were not pushing me
in any particular direction.
They were, you know, if I had wanted
to become an artist at that time,
I remember my father
saying well, you know,
we're not sure about this because
it was an academic family.
Academic, we know what to do.
Artist, we don't know what to do.
But they would not have
stood in my way if I had,
'cause I drew a lot as a kid.
And I was actually briefly an
art major here at Berkeley.
Until I got my C.
(both laugh)
- Which may tell us that
academic departments
in art are not the way to go.
- No, I got my C in
sculpture, I earned it.
I did not do any work.
I thought that if you had talent,
because it worked in drawing and painting.
I mean, I knew what to do
in my academic subjects.
And I just did it.
But in sculpture I didn't know
what to do, and I thought.
- So you come to Cal as an undergraduate,
and what did you major in?
- I finally graduated in anthropology,
but my honors thesis really
was a history thesis.
It was medieval Europe.
- And you traveled abroad, right?
- I did.
I was in the first class
of education abroad,
which just celebrated
its 50th anniversary.
- And where, where, where,
where did you go abroad?
- [Nell] Bordeaux, France.
- And there you got
interested in French history.
- I did, I did.
And French medieval history was one
of my four fields for my doctorate.
- And then, you also went to Africa.
- After I graduated.
- And all of these, all these places
were opening you up to,
to the world but also I guess leading you
to broaden your horizons with regard
to what you were going to study.
- Absolutely, absolutely.
And I have said many times,
and I'll still say it.
Those two years in Ghana actually,
if I had not lived in Ghana for two years,
I would be a crazy person, as are so many
of my fellow Americans, because
racism drives you crazy.
- And what about the French experience.
Did that, did that, was that a place
where you also could
discover black culture
and its legitimacy there?
- No, no there was no black
culture that I discovered.
And I also didn't discover
the big story of Bordeaux
in the early 60s, which is that Bordeaux
is where the kainua and
the what are called aqui,
the French allies in Algeria.
So if I had known, it would
have been a fascinating study.
What I learned there
was just to want to know
about the past of what
I was walking through.
And so, my way back into history
was through French medieval history.
I couldn't do it at that point
through American history.
- And then where did you
do your graduate work?
- I did my first graduate work
at the University of Ghana.
I got my MA in African history from UCLA,
and my PhD in American
history from Harvard.
- And what led you back
to American history?
Did you already have the
bug of thinking about
your people and their history
in the context of America?
- Let's see.
I just told you about sort of going
through Bordeaux and then Africa.
And I actually went to
Harvard to do African history.
But I got there before
the African historian.
I am awfully unstable,
and I tend to go into
whatever it is I'm studying.
So I was doing American
history, I thought,
oh, this is different from what I had
brushed up against in high school.
- Students often watch our program,
and I always like to ask the guests,
and in your case as a historian,
what do you think are the skills
necessary to do history well?
- The first is curiosity.
That is, you have to
want to know something
you don't already know.
And the second is to have your eyes
and ears open as you go to the archive.
And read more than once.
One of the books I did,
it's not under my name.
It's called The Secret Eye.
And it's the diary of
a plantation mistress
in the Deep South.
And I read the typescript,
1,380 pages, eight times.
And by reading it and rereading it,
I found how the various comments
over the years worked together,
and how this woman was keeping secrets.
And I actually discovered
one of the secrets,
which was an outside
family of her husband's.
I did not discover the other
secret that she hid too well.
Which was her husband's drinking.
But the descendants told me about that.
So know the sources well.
And ask questions that haven't been asked.
And what I find particularly interesting
is to ask new questions of old sources.
- And the new, part of your goal I guess
is to bring a new perspective,
so you can define those questions.
- I wouldn't say that's a goal.
But that's part of my process.
- What about temperament?
The temperament of a historian.
Are there certain characteristics?
- Well, I'm not a good example of that.
Because even though I have
had a very satisfying career,
I have not succeeded as a great historian.
So I don't know how to
succeed as a great historian.
I am the kind of historian, the only kind
of historian that I could be.
And that is because I love history.
- And I sense that you,
one of your missions
is to educate the public
about the discoveries
that your curiosity has led you to.
- You know, I really haven't had missions.
(laughs)
The only time I had
missions and had a plan
was when I started art school in 2007.
And I had a plan that I
wanted to do a BFA and a MFA.
But before that, I was just
wandering around in the world
asking the questions that interested me.
So, you know, why are white
people called Caucasian?
You know, that's how The
History of White People started.
Creating Black Americans
was a project brought to me,
saying would you like to do this?
But I don't even remember
how it was that I decided
to use Black fine art
as the illustrations.
Perhaps because I was
already drifting that way.
But by and large, I have satisfied myself.
That's a very selfish way
of producing scholarship.
But that's been my process.
- One of your first major
books was on Sojourner Truth.
How did that work come about,
and tell us a little about her.
- Yes.
That's a perfect example of my process.
So I started thinking about it in the mid,
late 80s or so, long time ago.
And what had struck me
was that Sojourner Truth
is known in words as
this fiery abolitionist
who's ripping open her bodice
and telling off people and
all this sort of thing.
Ain't I a woman, which she didn't say.
She did not say.
Aren't I a woman, she did not say.
But these were, this sort of
fiery persona was the verbal.
The images were this ladylike person,
sometimes sitting with
pictures of her grandson,
who was in the Union Army.
Sometimes with her knitting,
which always pleased me,
because I'm a knitter.
And she was a bourgeois,
and she was well-dressed.
So what is going on here?
So what I wanted to do was figure out
where Sojourner Truth was in that.
And what I discovered was the process
of making and remaking.
So it's Sojourner Truth, A Life.
Where was she, what did she do?
And the symbol.
What have we, we in the 19th century,
we at the turn of the 20th century,
we in the mid-20th
century, what have we made
of her as a symbol.
- And let's tell our audience
a little about her as a person.
She had been a slave in New
York, in New York of all places.
And then through her
revelations and her embrace
of an evangelical kind of Christianity,
she became an abolitionist
who was nationally known,
met with Lincoln and so on.
- She, the state of New York,
freed its adult slaves in 1827.
So, she was legally freed.
She walked away a year earlier
because she felt her owner had reneged
on a verbal arrangement they had made.
And she was moving into what were
then called New York Perfectionists,
people we would call
Pentecostals and evangelicals.
So she was in this group of people
in Ulster County, and in New York state,
in New York City, sorry.
And during the Millerite
excitement of 1843,
when thousands of Americans
expected the world to end,
she, well the Holy Spirit
spoke to her and said
you are no longer Van Wagenen.
You are no longer Isabella, you are truth,
you are Sojourner Truth.
And so then she started preaching.
And she followed a Millerite network
up the Hudson River valley,
and ended up in the end
of that year in the fall,
when it started getting cold,
in a place called Florence, which is,
was a center for abolitionists
right there by Northampton.
And it was in Northampton,
Florence and Northampton,
that she got to know abolitionists,
and found her calling as an abolitionist.
And at that point, we're
talking 1833, 1844 into 1850,
the community of, the
anti-slavery community
was also a feminist community.
So she was right at home.
And she actually dictated her narrative,
and she set out in 1850,
in 1851 to sell it.
And her marketing strategy you might say
was to visit anti-slavery feminists.
- So, so in a way, in the process
of writing this book, on the one hand,
you were a traditional
historian telling a narrative,
writing a book, but also
academic articles about her.
But you were struck by the
importance of the visuals,
which you've already described.
- Yeah, and that's where it
started with Sojourner Truth.
Sojourner Truth did not read and write.
So everything we know of her in text
is mediated by somebody else.
I mean, this is, mediation is the story
of everything we know, even for images,
even for photography, they are mediated.
But especially in terms of
the words for Sojourner Truth.
As you go through the passage of time,
the word picture of her changes.
So, the question is, what did
she want us to know of her?
Well, the answer is in photographs.
So I ended up doing a chapter
on Sojourner Truth's photographs.
Thank heaven I had access to an excellent
art history library at Princeton
and took advantage of it.
So that's where the art started.
- And so what did you learn
from the pictures about her,
her presentation of self,
that helped shape your history of her?
- Well, what I learned from
her self-fashioning visually,
which she controlled, when
you pay for the photographs,
you decide how you're
going to be photographed.
She decided to wear her nice clothes.
She didn't dress as a slave,
she didn't dress as a worker.
She didn't foreground her wounded hand.
She had wounded a hand
during her enslavement.
If she wanted to present
herself as a pitiable slave,
she could have put her injury up front,
which is what the Civil War soldiers did
who were trying to raise
money with carte de visible.
They put their injury right out
to solicit, you know, donations.
She presented herself as someone
who was proud of herself.
Who was well-dressed, who was composed,
and interestingly enough,
who wore eyeglasses.
- And so,
the work becomes really sort of boring in
to find the evidence for the
creation of the narrative
by the historical figure in a way.
So she was writing her own history
in a way that was different from what
might have been other images.
- Yes, yes.
But she was not writing.
She was making.
- Making, yeah.
- She was making images.
And they were very different
from the various versions
of text narrative.
- So, when one looks at the titles
of your work, it seems, as a historian,
part of your challenge is to
find different perspectives
on the story we tell
ourselves about ourselves.
- Yeah, I guess my perspective
is a different one,
because I work out of my own,
my own vision, my own views.
- Right, and so it's
really, and often the,
on the one hand, it's the
story of marginal peoples.
That is, people that have
been marginalized by society,
and we don't know their
story in the same way,
when you looked at the
posters on the wall in
elementary and junior high
school and high school,
there were stories that weren't there
when you were going to school.
That's right.
But in this sense, I am a marginal person.
So the way I see the world is going to be
the way a marginal person sees the world.
- And what you're finding
is a very rich history
from a very different perspective
than let's say the white male historians
that preceded you had done.
- I don't think the
body writes the history.
But there have been large blank spots
in historical writing.
So I think you can say
that there are people
independent of their bodies who write
from a black point of view,
not the black point of view,
but a black point of view,
whose bodies are not black.
Whose bodies may not be female,
but whose vision is an
open vision in this way.
So,
it's not about the body as a body.
It's about the body as a
way of seeing the world.
Maybe not the body, but the spirit
as a way of seeing the world.
- And
in the case of your, your
book on the progressive era,
sort of the untold stories
of the progressive era.
Does the history that you find
resonate with the experiences
that we're going through in our own time?
It would seem that the,
talking about the marginalized
people in the progressive era
really resonates with America,
especially after the crash of 2008.
- I wrote that book in the 1980s.
And it,
it was,
my editor kept wanting me to respond
to historians' controversies.
To the historiography.
So I went into the historiography,
and I said, well, what's going on here?
So, the question of what is going on
is how I got started in the way I wrote.
And, so there's a lot about taxes,
and democracy, and plutocracy.
Because the late 19th century
was that kind of time.
I thought we were living in
that kind of time in the 80s.
When I first published the book in 80,
what, six or something like that,
it kind of fell flat.
The lefty historians
wouldn't even review it.
It was a non-book.
Somehow, it has stayed alive.
It's in a second edition,
a 21st century edition.
And recently, I got, I got a royalty check
That was in the four figures!
This book has finally found its place.
Because it's about issues
that haven't gone away,
and that people are now seeing
in a way they couldn't
see in the 80s or the 90s.
- In a way, it suggests to me that,
reading the body of your work,
that there's an element in courage.
In writing about things that may not be
recognized as important at
the time you're writing.
And that you sort of have to wait
until what's going on in the world
meets the historical
account that you've written.
- I agree with you entirely
about the second part.
Luckily, I will probably live long.
(laughs)
but people have often said
to me, you're so brave.
You're so brave.
And I think, I'm not brave.
I'm just doing what I want to do.
(laughs)
- So it's interesting,
because it sort of suggests
that the opportunity to,
and at the same time to be,
shall we say idiosyncratic.
Those two can come together.
And maybe in the long term, it elevates
society's knowledge about itself.
- Hopefully, I hope so, I hope so.
But as you were talking,
the theme that was
going through my mind,
remember I said earlier
that the older I get, the more
grateful I am to my parents.
That it's my parents who gave me that,
that support, and said go ahead and do it.
I don't always look at myself
through other people's eyes.
Which is a crippling
habit of subaltern people.
It's very hard not to do.
But if you do it, you'll
never do anything.
- Talk a little about your parents again,
because is it that
there was provision for,
in addition to their individual strengths,
and their personalities
and their love of family
is a blessing that comes
with middle class life?
- Absolutely.
The fact that we didn't
have to worry about money
made all the difference in the world.
- And is this something
that you saw in your
history of the progressive era,
that when things get bad, you know,
the support for that kind of existence
for more and more people is diminished?
- I didn't see it so much
in Standing at Armageddon,
because it's a much more political book.
Political economy.
Where I saw it was when I thought about
women and women's history.
Because over and over again,
the people whose education
gets sacrificed when hard
times hit, it's women.
And the people who get pulled away,
or who get killed, or beaten,
or whatever that stands
in the way of your scholarly
work, say, those are women.
- Did you experience, in becoming
a historian who happens to be a woman,
did you experience
discrimination as you were making
your way into the profession?
Because, you know, all of this opening up
for women and for African-Americans
comes during your time.
- Absolutely, and I count myself
as very fortunate that I made it through.
In those days, I'm talking about the 70s,
as a woman of any background,
you had to have allies.
And I had allies, I was
very grateful for that.
But I wouldn't say so much discrimination.
But it's more the sort of,
the habits that may pass you by.
The mentoring you may not get.
The discouragement may come your way.
That kind of thing.
And once again, thanks to my parents,
I have a pretty strong ego.
But I remember people
who it just got down.
People who didn't get tenure,
people who just got beat up.
People whose physical health
was not as robust as mine.
So I'm also blessed I'm very healthy.
And if I had had say lupus or you know,
some other kind of crippling disease,
diabetes, I wouldn't have had my life.
- I believe I read somewhere
that you said that when you
did the Sojourner Truth book,
you really, psychology
was another dimension.
That is, the psychology of the slave,
and the psychology of people who have
been mistreated by society.
- Yes, yes, absolutely, absolutely.
And so in that book and in
my Penguin Classic Editions,
actually, two Penguin Classics,
one of Incidents in the
Life of a Slave Girl,
and one of Narrative of Sojourner Truth,
I stress the psychological side
of being in a violent
institution such as slavery.
And social scientists
have studied what happens,
or not necessarily what is
going to happen to people,
or what must happen to
people who are the victims,
or the witnesses, or the
perpetrators of violence.
But what they're vulnerable to.
And so we know your risks
if you're in a violent institution.
And slavery was a supremely
violent institution.
- So in a way, with this
idiosyncratic approach,
and I'm just, this is a word
that I want to be careful in using,
but the opening up of opportunity
and your sensitivity to
these marginalized groups,
you're able to bring a perspective
that opens up new areas of history.
- I would hope so, I would hope so.
- And that, in other words,
had previously been
ignored, not completely.
- No, no, I really do belong
to a class of historians.
- Yeah, who have worked on this.
Now tell us a little about your book
Creating Black Americans,
which I happen to have here,
and which is a beautiful book.
But this is a book where
all of your background
comes together in a way because
you're telling a narrative,
but you're saying the
narrative is not enough.
Why not, and what does
that lead you to do?
- The book has two voices in a sense,
which you picked up on.
One is the narrative history.
It is a narrative history
based on scholarship.
So it's, you know, it's not breastfeeding,
it doesn't have a point of view.
It tells you a lot of
stuff you need to know.
You should be able to read
this book no matter what
your politics, no matter
what your background,
and feel confident that the
information it purveys is sound.
On the other hand, many people have dealt
with African-American history
in the heart with emotion, with feeling.
As a historian, I couldn't do that.
So I let artists do that.
And one of the things
artists have done about--
- Black artists.
- Yes, they're all black artists.
That was a conscious decision I made,
that it's Creating Black Americans.
So they're all black artists,
and all the images have
to do with history.
So it's not a history of black art.
It's a certain
thread in the work of black artists.
But in some places, you find more
than one image of a figure.
Say like Martin Luther King Jr.
Or Sojourner Truth, or Frederick Douglass,
to point out that there is
not one stable way of seeing
people of importance in the past.
And that they are figures.
And artists have done
with them as they will
from their own individual point of view,
and from the time they were working,
and what they wanted to show.
So the images are not this is what
Frederick Douglass looked like.
You know, no pretense of that.
This is what one artist said,
and this is what another artist said.
This is what I'm doing.
- So in a way, you're telling us
that history is about many histories.
And the opening up of
different perspectives
to bring a larger and
larger narrative together.
And that artists can contribute
an emotional component
to our understanding of the past.
- Exactly, exactly.
- And so these two, so
there's no rejection
of the traditional narrative.
It's really the two perspectives
coming together in one book
to give a richer history.
- Yes.
And at some points, there was
a little bit of difficulty.
Because it, I remember
that I wanted to include
the work of an artist here,
in Oakland and Berkeley,
Mary Lovelace O'Neal, marvelous painter,
but she's an abstract painter.
And my editor said no, we want this book
to be used in classes, and
it'll take too much time
for teachers to learn to
talk about abstraction,
and then to talk to
their students about it.
So unfortunately, her work did not
make it into the final book.
- Now, your most recent book
is a history of white people basically.
Now, this is another case in which
you tell a story from a
surprising perspective.
I mean, do white people need
to be told their history?
- Well, if they want to buy the book.
(laughs)
- That's right.
But you're bringing
something to the table.
Talk a little about that.
I mean, what were you discovering
in the process of doing this?
- This was another book that
started with a question.
You remember at the end
of the 20th century,
there were the wars in Chechnya?
Which is the Caucasus.
And I'm thinking why are white
Americans called Chechens?
And that's where it stated.
Why are white people called Caucasian?
And so to answer that,
it took many, many pages,
and then I had to set it up.
And then you can't just
leave people there,
so it comes to the present.
But it started to a question.
And when I first started working,
I mean, I would get several,
people would say what are you working on,
and I'd say, you know, the
history of white people.
And some people would say
well that's interesting.
And some people would say,
are you writing it as a black person.
First I would say I'm
writing it as a historian.
And then I thought, well, that's kind
of a stiff-necked answer.
And I would say I'm
writing it as a white man.
But before really got to use that answer,
(Harry laughs)
people stopped asking
the question in that way.
So between about 2000, 2001
and 2005, six, seven, eight,
enough change that I wasn't getting
that kind of a question
with a hostile edge anymore.
Every now and then,
somebody will approach me
and say the book is about settling scores,
and I'm gonna get back at white people.
It's not that at all.
- And what you wind up
discovering in a way
is that, say, in the case of Emerson,
very important figure in American history,
you see that a white person
was really just a Saxon, for him.
- For him.
No, no, no, no.
There were different
kinds of white people.
And one group of white
people who were inferior.
They were white people, but
they were the Celtic race.
And then the superior white
people were the Saxons.
- And where did he come down on this?
- Of course he's a Saxon.
- Right, right.
So in a way, over time,
the notion of who is a white person,
we're all in this together,
broadens over time.
- First of all, things
change, your main point.
Absolutely, that's the point of the book.
Things change.
But what's hard for many
Americans to understand
is the idea of one great big white race,
and no subdivisions within
it, that's a creation of,
basically, the second
half of the 20th century.
And before that, there
were many white races.
And we just talked about
Emerson's two, Saxon,
he had more than two, but the big two.
I mean, he was in the Boston area.
The big two were the Celts and the Saxons.
So it wasn't that Irish
people and Irish-Americans,
or later on, Italian people,
Italian-Americans became white,
they were always recognized as white.
The men could vote.
However, they were inferior
white races for awhile.
So the terms changed.
In Emerson's mid-19th
century, it's Saxons.
By the late 19th century,
the Irish are kind of getting elevated
by the southern and eastern Europeans.
And then there's a new term
in the early 20th century, Nordic.
And Nordic is all northern Europeans.
So the Irish are put in.
And
then by the Second World War,
the Cold War, suburbanization,
then the Italian-Americans and the Jews
and the Slavs and everybody,
they're into white.
So anthropologists of the 40s and 50s
kept saying no, no, no, there are not,
there's not more than one white race.
There's caucasoid, mongoloid and negroid.
Those are the races, the real races.
And people keep asking me, you know,
what are the real races?
And there aren't any real races.
You just make it up
depending on who you are,
to whom you're speaking,
for what purpose, and when.
- And it's really, the big hurdles become
when you have to move from what has become
a larger and larger white category
to it being inclusive with
regard to Asians and blacks.
And I get the sense that
you're trying to show
that we're all in this together in a way.
That as, just as there have been changes
within the white race, and the recognition
of more and more people
as being part of that,
the same will be true
with regard to Asians
and to blacks over time.
That's your idea.
- This is becoming true.
Until about 2005 or so.
After the discovery of the human genome,
you know, we're all 99.99% the same,
race is a cultural production,
a social construct,
there's one race, it's the human race.
And then after that,
we've been re-racializing.
And so there was an op ed
piece in the New York Times,
I am a racial profiling doctor,
and selling a certain heart
medication for black people,
even though it works
for some white people.
You know, we are re-racializing.
I think, I hope that it's
kind of a desperate last gasp
before we realize that what
makes the big difference
is opportunities and money
and power and wealth and so forth.
And if I ran things, we would
be collecting census data
and making it available to people
according to wealth and income,
less race, more economic status.
But I can't say where we're going.
And certainly we're a country
of over 300 million people.
So we're not all going together.
- You are now an emerita professor.
And you didn't take that as
the occasion to really retire.
But you took it as an
occasion to start over.
- That's right.
- In a way.
And let's talk a little about that.
Because this is really a second career.
And in the first career,
we've come to understand
that you felt the narrative needed
to be complimented by the visual.
And so now, you've gone back to school.
Talk a little about that and
what led you to do that new career.
- Well, I had,
I had been in art in the 60s.
And failed, you might say.
And then Sojourner Truth pulled me back
in with the photographs,
and Creating Black Americans
with the work of black artists,
and realizing that there was a long
tradition of black artists.
I had company.
My mother starting again at 65.
You know, you don't have
to just lie down and stop.
So I started again as an undergraduate
at Mason Gross School of the
Arts at Rutgers University.
The state institution, the state
university out in New Jersey.
And I did a BFA, I graduated in 2009.
And then I went to the Rhode
Island School of Design
and I did a master of fine arts,
both degrees in painting,
and graduated in 2011.
And then I flopped around
trying to figure out
how to put the two parts
of my life together.
Because in art school,
particularly in graduate school,
they kept wanting to
disappear the historian.
And I, they wouldn't let
me use text in my painting.
So I would sneak text in sometimes.
- Meaning by that, what do you mean
you would sneak text in.
- No writing.
- Oh, writing.
(both laugh)
Into your artwork, okay.
- Yes, and I actually made one painting
that had a footnote.
(both laugh)
Which was so universally despised
that I painted out the footnote.
But I now have a piece on my wall
that's work in progress
that does have a citation.
And I swear that I'm gonna put
some footnotes in my paintings.
In the summer, I did a little book
that I called Art History Volume 27
by Nell Painter Ancestral Arts.
And it's 20 pages including the front,
and the back, and the cast of characters.
Otherwise no text.
And I printed it at Staples.
And I sent it to my friends.
And some of my friends are art people,
and they said you should make
this into a real artist book.
Which I'm going to do after
I finish here in Berkeley.
But meanwhile, the Staples
edition has been acquired
by the Beinecke Rare Book and
Manuscript Library at Yale.
And they will acquire
the archival version,
the archival version will also go
to the Du Bois Institute at Harvard.
And also to the, now a building,
National Museum of African-American
History and Culture.
So that started with a presentation I made
at the Metropolitan Museum in March 2013,
where they invited me
and some other people
to talk about an exhibition
on African Art in New York.
And I thought, I looked
at what had been done,
and it was very interesting.
It was about curators and collectors,
and the artists you would recognize.
And I thought, well, what
do I know about this?
And so the Harlem
Renaissance popped into mind,
and particularly Alain LeRoy Locke's
statement about African art being
the ancestral art for African-Americans.
So I said I think I'll start there.
And I actually did research.
So now, part of my
freedom as a visual artist
is to do historical research
and then make that visual.
And I discovered that the
artists did not agree with Locke.
They said we don't want to be cast
into a sort of straitjacket
of African art.
We want to be open to
the art of our times.
And I also discovered that
the sort of quintessential
Harlem Renaissance
artists, a man who had done
the illustrations for the
Survey Graphic Harlem issue,
and also for the book
New Negro, was German.
And was very much influenced
by artists like Otto Dix,
a German post-Expressionist artist
who I knew and whose work I admired.
So my visual presentation
brought in new material.
That was historical material.
But, the little book I
made didn't have words.
- And it was a collection of
these works of art by others?
- No, I made the art.
- Oh, you made the art.
- I made the art.
- Okay, all right, okay.
And you have in mind
to do a book on beauty.
I saw somewhere.
- I did, I did.
And I had a contract
that I went to art school
between signing the contract
and giving them the book.
And so I remade the book.
Into a book that was as much
image, as my images, as text.
And I gave it to my agent and my editors,
and they all said. (gasps)
No book.
- So what have you learned
from your work in art
that moves you beyond
all your work in history.
- Golly.
I love both.
And now I know I don't have to choose.
But with the art, because
there's such a range
of eyes looking at the work, I
do much more pleasing myself.
I haven't quite, maybe I haven't found
my audience as an artist yet.
I'm not sure.
But I feel much less certain
about what I'm doing,
and end up simply doing what I want to do.
I guess you could say
that's how I did history.
But I knew, I knew the
standards in history.
I knew, I knew when my work
was good historical work.
I don't know exactly
when my work is good art.
And it may not be good art.
But one of the great
things about being old
is it's okay.
- And how would you characterize
your art for an audience?
I know you have a website
and I saw some of it there.
But what is its current direction?
- Well, the current work
is not on the website,
it's on a website of a
gallery in Newark, New Jersey
where I live called City
Without Walls, CWOW.
So if you go to CWOW and
look for me under artists,
you'll find more recent work.
But my work is digital and manual,
so what I will be showing in my
presentation, the Jefferson
Lecture is digital collage.
And it was digital collage that I made
for this little art history book
and will make for the
bigger art history book.
I also do self portraits
because I don't mind
how I look in my work, and
I'm also always present.
So I'm a very handy model in that way.
And then I do, I do paintings
that are literally paintings.
So the manual side.
When I paint manually, I work
on paper and I work on canvas.
And I use, I use acrylics,
some of them are heavy bodied.
More and more I use very light
bodied inks, acrylic inks.
- And one final question.
Looking back on your amazing career,
what lessons might students who watch
this interview learn from your odyssey?
- Well, I don't know if my
odyssey applies to other people.
Because I consider myself a
uniquely fortunate individual.
Very blessed.
But I would say to others
do what you want to do and do your work.
Do a lot of work.
- Well, on that note, Professor Painter,
I want to thank you for coming to Berkeley
to be the Jefferson lecturer
and to be on our program.
- Thank you.
- And thank you very much for joining us
for this conversation with history.
(bright music)